dans la présidente est désormais célèbre
puisque chantal jouanno a décidé de ne
pas s'occuper de ce débat parce que on a
rendu publique sa rémunération près de
15000 euros par mois qu'elle a considéré
que ça pouvait faire des vagues voir
contrarier l'issue du débat
cette décision de se retirer la prise au
dernier moment comme elle l'a confié ce
matin à nos confrères de france inter
à quel moment avez vous pris cette
décision hier en constatant et en
prenant effectivement tous ces
questionnements autour de mon niveau de
salaire et plus largement d'ailleurs un
celui des présidents d'autorités
indépendantes et donc des hauts
fonctionnaires étaient sur la table
qu'il ne crée vraiment pas les
conditions de sérénité pour mener à bien
ce débat qui a vraiment besoin de
conditions de sérénité
et donc c'était un frein à la tenue du
débat la polémique serait revenu en
permanence plus souvent qu'à lens cette
polémique c'est un épiphénomène ou bien
ça ça va marquer durablement et pas
forcément dans le bon sens ce grand
débat il faut l'inscrire dans le film
des événements depuis plusieurs semaines
et à ce titre là c'est un épisode
supplémentaire qui démontre la
cacophonie et l'absence d'ordre et de
discipline au sein du mécanisme
gouvernementale de façon générale donc
je pense pas qu'il faille accablé madame
jouanno en l'occurrence est une décision
qui fait montre les certaine dignité de
refuser la polémique et de refuser de
corrompre le débat national par cette
polémique là mais en revanche
tout cela démontre clairement que cette
question n'est pas maîtrisée donc à
travers le salaire de madame jouanno
c'est le débouché même l'objectif le but
de ce dialogue national de ce grand
débat qu'on nous promet si fertile qui
est en cause et ça je trouve que c'est
très dommageable d'autant plus qu'en
france nous n'avons pas la tradition de
débats nationaux dont ils sortent quoi
que ce soit et et s'il arrivait s'il
advenait que ce débat aboutisse à
quelque chose et ce serait celle de mon
point de vue une nouvelle historique
on va parler ensuite un des différents
thèmes qui vont être abordés sur le
principe même de ce débat et sur son
organisation mais être ici place que est
ce que vous y croyez ou est-ce que vous
êtes aussi dubitatif dubitative pardon
collègues que les christian makarian
c'est sûr qu'on n'a aucune tradition de
ce genre de débat c'est une bien c'est
une évidence
je voudrais dire aussi que la cndp était
pas forcément la plus agression de la
commission du débat public pour mener ce
genre de débat parce que c'est pas du
tout ça qu'elle fait elle fait des
débats locaux précis sur des problèmes
très particulier c'est le contournement
de strasbourg c'est que va-t-il devenir
de l'aéroport de nom c'est milliards aux
aidants c'est d'ailleurs ce que cette
consultation et non
est ce vous parle c'est de notre dame
des landes nationale ce qui va se passer
un maintenant qu'est ce qu'on va faire
de l'aéroport de nom ou de lignes à
haute tension sur un tracé d'eau qu'il
ya beaucoup de débats publics qui sont
généralement très très bien mené mais ce
type de débat c'est absolument pas dans
les habitudes et dans le savoir faire d
membre de la commission nationale du
débat public pas du tout donc de toute
façon je ne suis pas sur quelles que
soient les qualités de mende journée qui
était sans doute une personne habilitée
tout à fait respectable peut-être pour
se lancer dans l'opération mais ce n'est
vraiment pas leurs habitudes
donc la question qui se pose c'est avec
qui le faire moi j'ai quand même plutôt
tendance puisque on est embarqué dans
cette affaire je me demande si les
maires les maires ruraux qu'on
commençait déjà à ouvrir les cahiers de
doléances il est maire serait pas les
plus à même dans un premier temps tout
au moins de récolter les avis des uns
des autres
sachant que qui va aller écrire des
choses sur les cahiers de doléances
est-ce que ça va être les plus sexy des
gilet jaune est ce que ça va être tout à
chacun de citoyens qui vont avoir envie
d'aller dire un certain nombre de choses
et comment tout ça va remonter comment
tout ça va être organisé ça peut être un
immense foutoir avec vous sa part 30 où
les sens et vous sera très difficile
d'arriver à quelque chose comme disait
ma grand-mère le pire n'est jamais sûr
alors pour ceux que ça intéresse les
missions les décrypteurs de ce matin
toujours sur figaro live était consacrée
à ce sujet auquel nous avons aussi
consacré la question sur le figaro.fr la
question d'hier gilet jaune croyez-vous
à l'utilité d'un grand débat national et
vous étiez 80% à répondre non c'est pas
un sondage sont les internautes du
figaro qui donnent leur avis mais enfin
il s'était quand même près de 85 me donc
c'est donc c'est pas mal chaque de
saint-victor avec le recul de
l'historien les cahiers de doléances pas
une première ça a marché dans le dans le
passé à lhassa un marché en 1789 avec
nous évidemment les conséquences qu'on
imagine et moi ça dépend pour qui tout
de même mais c'était pas du tout les
demandes des cahiers de doléances
d'ailleurs parce que les cas les
doléances est plutôt un témoignage comme
disait tocqueville de l'ancienne
monarchie et on n'a pas du tout envisagé
ce qui allait se passer par la suite
mais ce qui est très important c'est
qu'en effet ces cahiers de doléances à
cette époque là il était extrêmement
libre tout le monde pouvait dire ce
qu'il voulait et ça c'est très important
et moi j'ai le sentiment outre le fait
que ce gouvernement joue de malchance
il faut reconnaître que là on recolle
l'histoire de madame jouanno bon ça est
évident qu'elle devait démissionner eu
égard à son salaire parce que c'est
d'ailleurs à elle apparaît vite l argent
et job elle reste présidente d'une
commission dont on a bien dit qu en
effet elle s'occuper d'autres choses un
peu ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
démocratie participative
il est bien évident que c'est pas du
tout l'objet de ce grand débat et
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait normal
parce que ce grand débat porte sur des
choses qui vont bien au-delà des simples
questions c'est pour ça que suis assez
réservé sur l'idée que ça puisse se
faire au niveau des mairies simplement
il faut évidemment quelque chose de plus
important se met en place
je pense que ça peut pas marcher eu
égard aux circonstances
ce qui est vrai en revanche c'est qu'il
ya un immense besoin de d'expression de
possibilités pour les gens de dire ce
qu'ils ont au plus profond d'eux mêmes
parce que ce qui est en train se jouer
aujourd'hui et c'est pas spécifique à la
france
et c'est ça qui est vraiment très
important à comprendre c'est qu'il ya un
véritable sentiment ce qu'on appelle un
sentiment de dépossession
on l'a vu en italie on l'a vu en espagne
on la vit dans l'enceinte hymne un
sentiment tout cas au moins ont peu son
temps aussi et c'est une réalité et
c'est une réalité un tribunaux raison
mais je le sentiment fondé qui est fondé
notamment depuis 2005 tout le monde le
sait puisqu'il ya eu vraiment l'idée que
ont demandé au peuple des choses et on
faisait un peu le contraire l aslog
après le référendum
et ce n'est pas d'ailleurs le seul
exemple qu'on pourrait donner mais ce
que je voudrais pour finir il ya donc ce
besoin
il est clair que le gouvernement il doit
trouver une solution pour laisser
s'exprimer
ces gens dont classe à la base l'idée
d'un gros débat c'est plutôt astucieux
c'est plutôt pas trop mal simplement
déjà lorsqu'on
on entend les ministres nous dire que ça
on va pas toucher à tel débat on va pas
organisées telles choses il ya des
valeurs qu'on ne peut pas mettre en
cause et c'est à ce moment là c'est pas
la peine de faire un débat justement
venant à ces valeurs dont nous n'avons
pas le droit de parler benjamin griveaux
le porte parole du gouvernement l'a
expliqué hier soir sur bfm tv alors
c'est un débat
donc on peut parler de tout mais quand
même pas tout on ne tergiversera pas sur
les valeurs en revanche ça veut dire que
mme ivg ça veut dire que la peine de
mort ça veut dire que le mariage pour
tous ne seront pas sur la table
je le dis très clairement on appréciera
le rapprochement entre la peine de mort
et le mariage pour tous guillaume bigot
a peut-être un peu normal non peut pas
parler tous parce que sinon on n'en
finira pas ils sont prévus pour durer
deux mois je crois que ces débats c'est
vrai ce serait ce serait dommage ça
deviendrait une démocratie si on pouvait
parler de tout ce sera un peu dommage
non je caricature je crois que c'était
assez mal parti pour plusieurs raisons
je vous souvenez vous de cette
allocution où le président de la
république a annoncé la hausse du smic a
fait amende honorable
qu'est ce qu'il a dit ça ça a été peu
repris mais je trouve que c'était quand
même très surprenant il a fait cet aveu
extraordinaire puisqu'il a dit on pourra
parler de tout virgule y compris
l'immigration oui petit point et de
l'identité française c'est à dire qu'on
aura même le c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'était un aveu le fait que ce débat
était verrouillée était tabou d'une part
d'autre part on suit il ya eu un un
retour en arrière ça on en a quand même
quand même pas parler de ça à chaque
fois c'est un peu le même système avec
madame jouanno c'est le film de woody
allen prend l'oseille et tire toi on se
dit quand même c'est assez curieux parce
que elle garde ses émoluments où ça et
elle a tout à fait le droit d y aurait
payé correctement payés pour un travail
qui est difficile mais pourquoi elle se
retire du débat sans renoncer à sa
rémunération tout ça est quand même
quelqu'un cacophonique donc bien sûr que
c'est un jeu du pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement organise ce débat pour
qu'il y ait en effet d'expression pour
que les gens se soulageant quelque sorte
pour que cette cette colère ou cette
tension se résorbe à travers le verbe
c'est ça l'idée c'est faire diversion
c'est dans les entreprises jeune
enseigne dans une école de management et
les techniques assez
visiter notamment pour les grands
cabinets de conseil que quand vous
voulez faire passer une réforme un plan
de licenciement pardon de sauvegarde de
l'emploi on dit maintenant dans la
novlangue
qu'est ce que vous faites vous faites
une grande consultation tout le monde
peut parler s'exprimer
en réalité tout est verrouillé et tout
est ficelé et la décision ne changera
pas donc le hiatus est là pourquoi parce
que le gouvernement veut qu'il y ait
cette tension qui soit résorbée par le
verbe et du gilet jaune s'il participe
pour les autres citoyens d'ailleurs ils
participent à cette à ce débat c'est
bien sûr pour que ça débouche sur des
actions et un changement de politique
donc c'est là où depuis dès le départ si
vous voulez il y à il y a un vice qui
est plus qu un vice de forme qui est un
vice de fond en quelque sorte
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut dire on peut
dire que ce qui est intéressant du point
de vue des jets des jaunes c'est que ça
peut aider à structurer leur pensée est
en effet il peut y avoir une sorte
d'effet de cahier des doléances et 2.2
est de mon point de vue on est dans une
situation assez compliquée pourquoi
d'abord ce qu'on ait pu en septennat au
quinquennat
donc il n'y a plus cette soupape de
sécurité le maquereau est tout sauf un
grand homme donc il n'a pas la vista qui
lui permettrait par exemple de dissoudre
d'organiser de nouvelles élections ne
sert donc à pas faire ça serait prendre
un risque
il est oui mais le risque sinon c'est la
rue alors le risque beaucoup plus grave
à mon sens on va il ya eu une sortie
politique de cette crise sinon c'est un
problème d'ordre public très grave
on a aussi un problème de légitimité
béatrice hibou intéresse que des
français même de bonnes volontés réunis
dans des préfectures ou dans des mairies
sont légitimes pour décider de ce qui
doit être le calendrier législatif ou
celui des réformes ça veut pas dire que
ce qu'ils vont écrire sera acceptée mais
sinon ça sert à rien ça supposerait
qu'il soit tous d'accord et qu'il dise
des choses qu'ils soient tout à fait
sans contradiction ce dont je doute pour
ma part ça les hommes
in énormément bon donc il ne faut pas
penser que de la parole de tout à chacun
va sortir la vérité vraie et qu'elle
sera suivie on raisonne comme si dans
ces cahiers de doléances il y allait
avoir que des gilet jaune quel à écrire
non et gilet jaune
d'abord beaucoup de gilet jaune n'iront
pas finir ils n'iront pas écrire d'abord
parce qu'ils savent pas d'abord parce
que forme effet formulé sa pensée par
l'écrit c'est déjà quelque chose qui
n'est pas si simple que ça quand on dit
à monsieur griveaux qui fait des fautes
de français et madame chapeau quand les
tutoriels sur les chignons d'accord mais
quand on a perdu l'habitude parce que on
est pas entraîné a c'est pas un jugement
de valeur c'est une constatation c'est
moi les langues étrangères je ne parle
plus jamais je ne sais plus les parler
bon voilà donc quand on ne fait pas
quelque chose on ne sait plus le faire
donc je pense que l'on va déjà avoir un
autre type de gens qui vont l écrire
bien sûr qu'on aura de la colère on le
voit déjà d'ailleurs dans ce qui est
écrit
mais si par un effet des dieux favorable
on a une participation relativement
importante de gens qui vont exprimer un
certain nombre de choses et si derrière
ça il y à la structure adéquate pour
essayer de faire le tamis et sortir un
peu des grands axes bon ça peut
peut-être est quelque chose qui aide à
réfléchir et qui aura à leur d'espoir
quand même optimisme oui toute façon ça
sert à rien de passer son temps à dire
mais c'est nul ça va pas y arriver et
c'est une fois qu'on a dit ça au fond
n'a rien à faire non non non on n'a rien
fait avancer non 1789 on avait quasiment
90 % d'une population illettrée on
aggraverait alors je vous interromps
parce que j'ai pas encore sonné mais
voilà je n'ai pas encore donné la parole
aux internautes qui je suis obligé de le
dire sont aussi assez dubitatif nicole
sur lefigaro.fr nous dit ce débat ne
changera pas grand chose car il a de
fortes chances de l'être que de la fumée
compte tenu du nombre de succès du
nombre de sujets pardon qu'il ne faut
pas aborder allusion aux propos de
benjamin griveaux
même chose pour élan qui je ne crois pas
l'utilité de ce débat car des questions
les plus intéressantes
la loi de 1905 la procréation
médicalement assistée marrakech par
exemple ne sont pas abordés et puis on
n'empêchera pas les seins de la mort des
civils
et puis c'est un simulacre de débat nous
dit monsieur babineau et anti mac le dit
personnellement je pense que ce débat et
de l'enfumage je ne crois pas que macron
et ses collaborateurs soient compétents
pour le mener et puis ce témoignage
intéressant de long de nerfs qui comme
son nom l indique pas nous écrit depuis
la suisse en nous disant ici en suisse
on se dit que les français vont vers le
même système de votation d un certain
nombre de signatures votation nationale
puis législation en fonction du résultat
là on est plutôt proche du référendum
d'initiative n'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui donc ça on va pas le
traiter on va rester sur ceux qui ont
inspiré ou provoquer ce débat c'est à
dire les gilets jaunes pour parler de
l'appui peut-être inattendue qui l'ont
trouvé en particulier en italie
écoutez matteo salvini c'est le ministre
de l'intérieur italien le leader de la
ligue est l'un des deux mouvements au
pouvoir avec le le mouvement 5 étoiles
lui il dit deux choses 1
les gilets jaunes c'est formidable et 2
c'est l'occasion pour monsieur macron de
retourner à la case à auto se teignant
possible paris freine chase ou 4 min et
respectueusement tester nos façons de
présenter en président qui n'ont fait
l'intéressé pauvre française primagaz
améliorer premiers épisodes de violence
et la condamne à l'est
c est ce normal jacques saint victor
vous connaissez intimement liés